elle accuse René de l'avoir suivi dans
sa chambre d'hôtel l'avoir violé l'avoir
menacé de mort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça me manque d'être hutte anneilla
morair ça veut dire quelque chose
sur Instagram elle est elle a affirmée
aujourd'hui je ne vais être normal ne
plus mettre au faux-ongles plus de
coloration plus de make-up plus rien
abstinence totale sa maman tellement
d'être une quand même voilà c'était pour
te faire plaisir parce que je sais que
tu aimes tous ces gens d'Instagram
influence voilà je l'avais vu ce que
j'avais fait deux jours à Miami pour les
anges comme ça et c'était la saison elle
était là-bas elle m'avait chauffé de ouf
mais non
[Musique]
je comprends pas dans sa façon de
s'habiller non je voulais dire je pense
un peu oui
déjà on peut rien faire déjà je pense
que j'étais maqué enfin je pense et en
plus on ne peut rien faire c'est que
vous avez des caméras partout c'est ce
qui est incroyable c'est que vous
marchez dans dans l'appartement c'est
une super maison bord de l'eau là vous
passez derrière un poteau vous savez que
derrière un poteau il y a quelqu'un qui
est en train de filmer ou passer à côté
d'un d'un mur où il y a un rideau vous
donnez un coup de rideau parce qu'il y a
quelqu'un derrière
et elle a été photographiée dans les
rues de Londres arborant une robe où
elle est pratiquement nuit à deux
minutes laissant apparaître pratiquement
l'intégralité de sa poitrine et donc
c'est fans comme c'est comme ceux qu'il
a qu'il a critique depuis longtemps
c'est des tracteurs se demandent si elle
n'a pas replongé totalement excusez-moi
une robe décolleté on voit un joli sein
sur un mannequin ça en fait drogué tu
appelles ça un décolleté toi ça c'est un
décolleté jusqu'au nombril ce n'est pas
un décolleté Mathieu c'est une soirée
avec elle il y a une année
[Applaudissements]
et donc elle était là entourée de garde
du corps elle était déjà à moitié à poil
comme ça très joli il y a quelqu'un qui
peut se le permettre d'entourer de garde
du corps elle avait un charisme fou
quand le passé les gens s'écartaient
même pas besoin de dire du corps les
gens s'écartaient devant elle etc elle
est fantastique pour moi c'est une vraie
conne
et vous connaissez Céline
personnellement
on va l'expliquer les spectateurs René
accusé de viol dans les années 2000 il
faut comprendre que le 18 mars 2000 René
veut alors installer Céline au César
Palace à Las Vegas il rencontre dans une
salle de jeux parce qu'il jouait
beaucoup avec beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
au jeu une femme coréenne de 44 ans qui
portera plein deux ans plus tard pour
viol elle accuse renaît de l'avoir suivi
dans sa chambre d'hôtel l'avoir violée
l'avoir menacé de mort si sa femme
Céline la prenait René il va lui verser
2 millions de dollars contre son silence
mais ce qui dit lui c'est que il a pas
versé les deux millions de dollars parce
qu'il l'a violé qu'il a accompagné mais
qu'à ce moment-là céline est en train
d'exploser de sortir son album et qu'il
ne voulait pas de scandale pourquoi ça
sortirait maintenant pourquoi ça ne
serait pas sorti à l'époque c'est vrai
que René était un joueur invétéré qui
est passé des nuits à la table de poker
et qui effectivement est Céline le
savait avait tendance à aller voir des
dames de la joie parce que Céline
d'abord a été folle amoureuse de René et
René ne n'était pas du tout au fond
d'amoureux d'elle donc c'était pas à moi
et il avait aussi une vie disons
sexuelle pour pas dire
c'est incroyable vous me dites que
Céline Dion j'ignorer et je ne juge
personne chacun se coupe Céline Dion
savait très bien que le soir quand il
jouait de temps en temps René aller
aller faire l'amour avec des
professionnels oui mais j'ai dit au
début de leur carrière elle était pas un
peu lesbienne
et donc c'est vrai que elle a ce côté
androgyne elle a quand même pas des
nénés comme ça elle est plutôt au bon
assez plates elle est un peu masculine
elle a aussi un grand charisme de femmes
mais c'est vrai que ce n'est pas
ni Marilyn Monroe ni dit un petit coup
de cœur voilà c'est ce que je voulais
dire pour une femme
de coeur pour pépé Munoz qui était quand
même un garçon qui aime les garçons
mais pour une fille non et pour une
fille on ne nous le dira pas c'est ça
voilà Coolio et je rappelle donc Coolio
était il était justement de 59 ans et
jeudi soir il était découvert mort dans
sa salle de bain la salle de bain d'un
ami pardon à Los Angeles personne ne
saigne un rapport toxicologique qui a
été fait mais pour l'instant on n'a pas
encore les les données donc on sait pas
du tout s'il y avait de la drogue de
l'alcool on ne sait pas du tout est-ce
que tu en sais un peu plus d'alcool il
buvait pas
il a peut-être vraiment eu une crise
cardiaque c'est possible avec une vie
aussi intense peut-être à 59 ans oui
parce que il buvez pas d'alcool
mais bon donc là il a été trouvé dans la
salle de bain d'un de ses amis c'était
où à Los Angeles
il refaitait son passeport en fait et
donc il est resté là-bas tant de
récupérer le passeport et voilà d'accord
la dernière fois que tu l'as vu que tu
l'as parlé toi il y a pas très longtemps
en fait au mois d'avril j'étais à Miami
il avait eu sur ma story que j'étais à
Miami et
c'est quelqu'un qui est très intense qui
me dit je vais vous lire en français je
sais que tu es là il faut absolument
qu'on se voit mais je lui dis mais non
je suis pas coiffé
vraiment les moments et je lui dis
donne-moi une heure donc je me suis
préparé et on s'est vu au palme sur
South Beach le Palm Hôtel bah restaurant
et puis on a passé de 16h jusque jusque
quatre
vous êtes qui vous vous connaissez
quel est votre prénom on est désolé bébé
alors je te dis tout allez bandeau chez
arabes on avait on avait un trou dans
l'émission on avait un trou dans
l'émission
vous êtes qui s'appelle non je vous ai
jamais vu en disant de on ne sait jamais
vu d'accord mais vous m'avez vu
aujourd'hui alors vous avez des
émissions culturelles
tu te présentes avant de poser ta
question on sait jamais croisé parce
qu'avant je faisais des émissions
extrêmement culturelles d'accord
je m'appelle Sophie Coste la question
c'est vous n'avez jamais envie de faire
un enfant avec lui parce que il a
tellement fan on a l'impression qu'il a
la patate
cet homme-là pardon on a l'impression
qu'il a la paternité
c'est un garçon très sexuel et très
active non mais on peut être très sexuel
sans faire des enfants